plans for the world's largest
hydroelectric
project have been given new momentum
australia's fortescue metals group has
been awarded exclusive rights
to develop the grand inga network of
dams in congo that would be twice the
size
of the current global biggest the aim is
to use the powerful
inga fours at the mouth of the congo
river
to generate vast amounts of electricity
for it to work
up to six more dams on top of two that
are already there
and several power plants need to be
built the finished project would be
capable of producing at least
40 gigawatts of electricity that's
twice as much as china's three gorgeous
dam which is currently the world's
largest it's enough
power to cover 40 percent of africa's
power needs
total costs for the project are
estimated though to be around 80 billion
dollars
grandinga has been in the offing since
the 1990s but
until now there just hasn't been the
money around to make it happen
let's discuss the project further with
trisha reddy who
is a climate activist with the ngo women
africa she joins us from
south africa thanks for being on the
programme uh 40
of africa's energy needs filled with
renewable sources
that sounds like that can only be a good
thing
um yeah so that's an interesting one
because
big hydroelectric dams are always sort
of lumped
in together with renewable energy
and we believe that it's a very
controversial
sort of use of the term of renewable
energy we don't actually believe
that this idea of having big
hydroelectric dams
um should be considered um as part of
the overall sort of
electricity mix in terms of the the
transition to
to green energy but this would be a
major
shift away from fossil fuels
yes so i'm not sure about a major shift
away necessarily from fossil fuels
there's also a lot of other disastrous
projects coming up as well but
the the thing about big hydroelectric
dams is
it's very little known that there's also
you know massive impacts that they
actually cause
including climate impacts there's
several climate impacts that i would
wouldn't go into detail here but it's
very little known and so
is sort of used as a way to say that
um you know uh the these big dams are
basically
uh climate friendly and they really are
not
uh added to that of course are the other
impacts from big dams
uh there are massive displacements of
people
uh at the site of the dam uh who
usually um sort of depend on the water
from the
uh from the rivers there so from in this
case the the congo river there
um the first two uh
iterations of inga um in fact that were
built in the 90s i think
um people who are displaced from from
those dams at the time thousands of
people
uh have still not even been given
compensation for that
uh there's a huge amount of other
environmental impacts as well um
and in general basically as well as that
impact on the displacement of people
this project has the potential to create
maybe hundreds of thousands of jobs i
mean that's that's surely something
that's welcome
so that's a controversial issue as well
i mean um if you look at the case of
south africa for example
south africa is supposed to be the major
off-take of the electricity that's going
to be produced
from the inga dam um
the um sorry um the electricity that
that is
um created is is will actually create
no jobs in south africa uh in effect
no but in congo it will create many more
actually just because we're running low
on time and and your organization is
actually
um mainly focused on women's access to
resources and
why is your organization so interested
in the the inga the grandina project
i think because we see that most of the
major impacts are faced
and born by women ultimately
women because of their prescribed roles
as carers in communities
they're the ones who go and fetch the
water from
the rivers for their communities
uh they are the ones that actually
protect and defend the land
uh they grow from the land and so um
if if there's big destructive projects
like inga coming in
um you can see that there's going to be
multiple
impacts uh that they face because of it
if you look at south africa specifically
um
and this is all coming up from uh from a
latest report
um that we've just done which shows the
socio-economic costs
of the inga to south africa it shows
that women will be disproportionately
impacted as well
in a negative way in south africa okay
drew shared
from women africa thanks a lot for
joining us on dw business
thank you bye